representation matters authentic
representations of women matter I think
that too often our public
representations of women are enveloped
in the language of the extraordinary the
first American woman to become a
self-made millionaire
madam CJ Walker the dresses of the first
ladies of the United States
shirley Chisholm the first woman to seek
the US Democratic Party's presidential
nomination
as a museum curator I understand why
these stories are so seductive
exceptional women are inspiring in
aspirational but those stories are
limited by definition being
extraordinary is non representative it's
atypical those stories do not create a
broad base for incorporating women's
history and they don't reflect our daily
realities if we can collectively apply
that radical notion that women are
people it becomes easier to show women
as people are familiar diverse present
in everyone's every day throughout
history women exist positively not as a
matter of interpretation but as a matter
of fact and beyond a more accurate
representation of human life including
women considers the quotidian
experiences of the almost 3.8 billion
people identified as female on this
planet in this now notorious museum
scene from the Black Panther movie a
white curator erroneously explains and
artifacts to Michael B Jordans character
seen here an artifact from his own
culture this fictional scene caused real
debates in our museum communities about
who is shaping the narratives and the
bias that those narratives hold museums
are actually rated one of the most
trustworthy sources of information in
the United States and with hundreds of
millions of visitors from all over the
world we should tell
accurate histories but we don't there is
a movement some with in museums
themselves to help combat this bias the
simple acknowledgement that museums are
not neutral museums are didactic through
the display of art and artifacts we can
incite creativity and foster inclusion
but we are guilty of historical
misrepresentation our male-centered
histories have left our histories hidden
and there are hard truths about being a
woman especially a woman of color in
this industry that prevents us from
censoring inclusive examples of women's
lives museum leadership predominantly
white and male despite women comprising
some 60% of museum staffs pipelines to
leadership for women are bleak bleakest
for women of color and the presence of
women does not in and of itself
guarantee an increase in women's public
representation not all women are gender
equity allies in the words of feminist
theorists bell hooks patriarchy has no
gender women can support the system with
patriarchy just as men can support the
fight for gender equity and we often
downplay the importance of
intersectionality Marian Anderson was
one of the most celebrated voices of the
20th century and the Smithsonian
collected her 1939 outfit after the
White Daughters of the American
Revolution deny her access to sing in
Constitution Hall because she was black
she famously sang instead on the steps
of the Lincoln Memorial to a crowd of
over 75,000 people and in libraries all
over including museums you can still
find the groundbreaking 1982 anthology
entitled all of the women are white all
of the blacks are men that some of us
are brave demands for the increase in
women's representation does not
automatically include after Latinas like
me or immigrant women or Asian women or
Native women or trans women or
with women or women over 65 or girls the
list can go on and on and on so what do
we do targeted initiatives have helped
incorporate perspectives that should
have always been included I arrived at
the Smithsonian through a latino
curatorial initiative whose hiring of la
fenix curators mostly women by the way
has raised the profile for Latinas
narratives across our institution and it
served as a model for our much larger
Smithsonian American women's history
initiative which seeks to amplify
diverse representations of women in
every possible way so that women show up
not only in the imagery of our
contemporary realities but in our
historical representations because we've
always been here right now though in
2018
I can still walk into professional
spaces and be the only the only person
under 40 the only black person the only
black woman the only latina sometimes
the only woman my mother is
african-american and my father is afro
Panamanian I am so proudly and
inextricably both as an afro latina I'm
one of millions as an afro Latino
curator I'm one of very few and bringing
my whole self into the professional
realm can feel like an act of bravery
and I'll admit to you that I was not
always up for that challenge whether
from fear of rejection or self
preservation in meetings I would only
speak up when I had a fully-developed
comment to share
no audible brainstorming or riffing off
of colleagues for a long time I denied
myself the joy of wearing my beloved
hoop earrings or nameplate necklace to
work thinking that they were too loud or
unscholarly or unprofessional
I wondered how people would react to my
natural hair or if they viewed me as
more acceptable or less authentic when I
straighten it and anyone who has fell
outside of mainstream representations
understands that there are basic
elements just of our everyday being that
can make other people uncomfortable but
because I
passionate about the everyday
representation of women as we are I stop
presenting an inauthentic representation
of myself or my work and I have been
tested this is me pointing at my hoop
earring in my office just last month I
was invited to keynote a Latino Heritage
Month event the week of the presentation
the organization expressed concerns they
call my slides activist and they meant
that negatively two days before the
presentation they requested that I not
show a two-minute video affirming
natural hair because the quote may
create a barrier to the learning process
for some of the participants and quote
that poem hair was written and performed
by Elizabeth Acevedo a Dominican
American 2018 National Book Award winner
and it appeared in an award-winning
Smithsonian exhibit that I curated I
cancelled the talk explaining to them
that their censorship of me and my work
made me uncomfortable
[Applause]
respectability politics and idealized
femininity influence how we display
women and which women we choose to
display and that display has skewed
towards successful and extraordinary and
reputable and desirable which maintains
the systemic exclusion and
marginalization of the everyday the
regular the underrepresented and usually
the non-white as a museum curator I am
empowered to change that narrative I
research collect and interpret objects
and images of significance
Celia Cruz the queen of salsa yes is
significant and the now for latina this
myth Sounion has collected her costumes
her shoes her portrait her postage stamp
and this reimagining by artist Toni
Peralta when I collected and displayed
this work it was a victory for symbolic
contradictions pride in displaying a
dark-skinned latina a black woman whose
hair is and large rollers which
straighten your hair perhaps a nod to
light beauty standards a refined
glamorous woman an oversized chunky go
jewelry when this work was on view it
was one of our most instagrams pieces
and visitors told me they connected with
the everyday elements of her brown skin
or her rollers or her jewelry our
collections includes the Lea Cruz and a
rare portrait of a young Harriet Tubman
iconic clothing from the incomparable
Oprah Winfrey
but museums can literally change how
hundreds of millions of people see women
and which women they see so rather than
always the first or the famous it's also
our responsibility to show a regular
Saturday at the beauty salon the art of
door knocker earrings fashionable
sisterhood and cultural pride at all
ages stories of everyday women whose
stories have been knowingly omitted from
our national and global histories and
often times in museums you see women
represented by clothing or portraits or
photography
but impactful life changing stories from
everyday women can also look like this
Esmerelda in boat seat Esmerelda's
ecuador was a maroon community it's
dense rainforest protected indigenous
and African populations from Spanish
colonizers their roads now but there
were some parts inland that are still
only accessible by canoe Deborah Nasser
Renault frequently traveled those
Ecuadorian waterways by canoes so she
had her own boats eat hers personalized
with a spiderweb and a spider
representing a non-si a character in
West African folklore Deborah also saw a
misdeed at home telling stories to her
grandson Kwan and this intangible ritual
of love in the form of intergenerational
storytelling is common in communities
across the African Diaspora and this
everyday act sparked and Wand the desire
to collect and preserve over 50,000
documents related to Afro Indian culture
in 2005 Huang Garcia Salazar Deborah's
grandson and by now a world-renowned
Alfre Ecuadorian scholar traveled to
Washington DC he met with Lonnie bunch
the director of the museum where I work
and toward the end of their conversation
Kwan reached into his bag and said I'd
like to give you a present on that day
Deborah Dena Serrano's humble would
invoke seat became the very first object
donated to the Smithsonian National
Museum of African American history and
culture it is encased displayed and has
been seen by almost five million
visitors from all over the world I will
continue to collect from extraordinary
history makers their stories are
important but what drives me to show up
today and every day is the simple
passion to write our names in history
display them publicly for millions to
see and walk in the ever-present light
that is woman thank you
[Applause]